petite polémique dans les jardins
ouvriers de tours nord tout est parti
d'un courrier posté sur les réseaux
sociaux qui a enflammé la toile une
jardinière pratiquant la permaculture
s'est vu demander de quitter son terrain
car non respectueuses de la charte en
vigueur son poste a même été relayée et
commentée par l'ancien ministre de
l'ecologie delphine batho mais c'est
surtout le manque de dialogue qui a été
la source de friction et
d'incompréhension explications hélène
chapelet depuis mars dernier catherine
herrick exploite la parcelle numéro 11
du jardin ouvrier de la rue mayer à
tours 200 mètres carrés qu'il cultive en
permaculture à cause des deux
confinement ils n'ont pas pu s'y
consacrer autant qu'il le voulait mais
leur intérêt pour le jardinage pourrait
rapidement s'arrêter à cause de ce
courrier reçu un recommandé il ya une
dizaine de jours la présidente de
l'amicale des jardins les recadre par
écrit expliquant qu'il ne faut pas
laisser les plantes grainé vous polluez
vos voisins avec les graines s'échappant
des floraison des plantes non souhaitée
par les jardiniers du site
me référant à leur majorité je dois vous
demander de revenir à une culture
conventionnelle ou de nous quitter
un rappel à l'ordre qui passe mal et qui
manque peut être un peu de tact on n'a
pas bien compris la violence de ce
courrier et puis ça bat son irruption
sans qu'il y ait discussion préalable
donc non il ya une incompréhension
justement par rapport au fait qu' ils
vendent de la paille
on est plutôt dans la stupeur et
l'incompréhension et encore une fois on
est novice on est là puis à peine neuf
mois et on a quand même vu des récoltes
encourageantes
donc on nous a vraiment sapé dans notre
élan du côté de la présidence
on concède le manque de tact elle les
deux parties prenantes ne se sont jamais
rencontrées pour s'expliquer et parler
des attentes de l'association
c'est peut-être là le problème et non
pas la permaculture qu'attendait jusqu'à
l' réagissent canonise mamba je suis pas
d'accord avec ce que vous dites mais je
vais faire un effort pour l'année
prochaine c'est tout je n'ai pas virer
un je ne suis pas contre la permaculture
parce que moi même j'en fais dans mon
jardin je fais des lasagnes
j'ai des fleurs pour les oiseaux les
papillons aura tout ça mais dès que je
vois que les graines se forment et
ces saisons des graines je coupe ces
parcelles en bord de route sont une
vitrine des jardins ouvriers
ils doivent être productif certes mais
aussi joli à voir pour tous ceux qui
passent une notion d'esthétisme qui
n'est peut-être pas assez expliqué aux
nouveaux venus